okay this is a longer game so
we can really dig deep and talk about a
lot of concepts here
okay so what should we play um
let's uh let's play another sicilian
shall we
and hopefully we'll get a chance to
repeat the night or maybe we'll play
we'll play another night off
let's play sicilian
[Music]
all right yeah let's play a night off
now does anybody
i basically just gave it away how does
the night or
go what move does black play in this
position
so yeah d6 now we've mostly been playing
the accelerated dragon which i
which i'm teaching to charlie uh in the
speed run but
uh lately we've experimented a little
bit with the night or now we take this
is the open sitlian
knight f6 and after knight c3 we have
several possible moves g6 is the
traditional dragon uh there is knight c6
that is the
rouser or the classical sicilian there's
e6 there's e5
e5 is not great but uh the night or
is a special place in sicilian players
as hearts and that is the move a6
a6 and as we've discussed the
the sort of most uh immediate idea is to
cover the b5 square
right to stop the bishop the knight from
going to b5 and
chess ninja plays bishop tuna bishop b2
is one of the most popular responses to
the night or fade is considered to be
among white's quietest options so
it's okay quiet should be
taken within the proper context that
doesn't mean the position is
boring the position is still very
interesting but the reason this is
considered to be relatively quiet in
comparison is because white actually
wants to castle short whereas in many
lines bishop g5 bishop b3 white actually
castles long so you have opposite side
castling
now um neither flares are split
between two categories the categories
roughly
are e6 players and then e5 players
so e6 leads to a structure called the
cheveningen structure i'll talk about
this after the game
but i have always been an e5 player and
those of you who do not play the night
or this move might seem very strange
i don't remember if i talked about it i
think i did talk about it in the context
of another move so
uh maybe some of you guys were there for
my previous
uh previous explanation but if you
weren't and you don't you're not an
eidorf player
uh if if this move doesn't seem weird to
you then you're doing something wrong
why does this move look like a big
positional mistake
at first no it's no this is the
theoretical move why does this look like
a big positional mistake
what does it weaken yeah so it weakens
d6 and correspondingly weakens the d5
square
but this is why i don't recommend the
night off to beginners but this is
precisely why because you have to
violate these rules these basic
positional rules
and it's like you have to earn the right
to violate them you can only violate
them if you know them
and for beginners it's more important to
practice applying the rules
before you practice violate them
violating them if you practice violating
them first
you never practice applying them and you
build essentially
what will ultimately turn out to be a
rotten foundation
but in this game i will attempt to
explain
kind of by degrees why this is
justifiable to play five there isn't one
single reason
why black gets away with the movie five
it's a very complex
prop it's a very complex network of
different reasons
so first of all we have to develop our
pieces
that is the same in any
opening we have to develop our pieces in
particular we need to get our king out
of the center so bishop e6 is possible
uh and bishop e7 is also possible the
main move is bishop e7
you basically want to prepare castling
as early as possible
and also this bishop on c8 potentially
might be fianchettoed on b7
the first of the very constellation of
reasons why d5
square is not the end of the world is
that what black is a lot of pieces that
can contest
the d5 square in particular you could
put the bishop on e6
and this knight on f6 can be supported
by its brother on d7
so you can basically have two pieces
directly one piece indirectly
controlling the d5 square which makes it
incredibly hard for white to
actually get a knight on t5 and
establish it there in
practice because black is not a game
practice
because black has all of these pieces
clustered on the king side i hope that
kind of makes sense
so here we castle again we delay the
development of this bishop let's see
what white does
and that's reason number one why the
weakness of the d5 square is not
as devastating as it may appear the
second
sort of broad set of reasons consists in
the fact that
and bear with me for a second here black
has
counter play on essentially both sides
of the board
and one of the sources of black's
counterplay is this b-pawn advance to b4
so
even though d5 may be weak uh it is
often counter-balanced
by black's counterplay on both sides of
the board
and hopefully we'll get a chance to
spell that out concretely
that doesn't mean that games have not
been lost
because a knight has landed on d5 and
sat there until the rest of the game i
will even show you a game that i played
where i mishandled the position
mishandled it and i allowed a knight on
d5 and i lost the game that's the danger
of playing the night off that's not to
say d5 square is not important
okay now it is finally time
to deploy the bishop to e6 and add
another protector to the d5 square
queen d3 by the way is indeed a
legitimate
move in this in this position that is a
line but let's see how he follows it up
yeah so i'll explain i'll explain the
move
e6 after the game the chevening against
structure i used to play
but i never really liked it and i'll
explain some of the reasons why
one of the reasons why is that okay so
bishop g5 what should we do now
i've already explained the general set
of moves that black normally plays in
this position what do you guys think
should be preferred here
yeah so the move is
knight bd7 is correct and we get the
situation where
it's very hard to dislodge a knight from
f6 if
y takes then then we will simply take
back yeah
good and now
as i explained we have all four of our
miners clustered together in the center
which is actually kind of a good thing
and we are ready to begin queen side
operations queenside operations can
refer to
two specific different things the first
i
okay that and see that's the issue got
to be careful about this thing
because this can yeah so dropping the
knight is is chest ninja i'm going to
take it
um of course i could give him i could
not take the knight and stuff but i
don't really believe in that he'll get
another chance to play me
um i think that this is also something
instructive
and i'm going to make a lesson out of
this i know i might sound obnoxious
but part of the benefit of and charlie
will experience is part of the benefit
of playing something most people don't
play at a level
where people mostly play e5 is that
people get these unfamiliar positions
and unfamiliar positions result in
blunders that's not a coincidence that's
just something that
generally tends to happen okay
but let's continue playing we're up a
piece that's great but that doesn't mean
we shouldn't continue making night or
flight moves thank you grounded
132. could anybody propose a
typical sicilian move here we can
activate one of our other pieces and put
it on
a very nice little square
yeah so let the knights stay on d7 the
knights are kind of good here
yeah rook aca those of you who play the
sicilian i mean this is just such a
typical move applying pressure on the
night
many times you do want to sacrifice the
exchange on c3
that is also a legitimate idea but here
we won't need to do that because world
of peace
it also is not a bad idea at some point
to tickle the bishop with h6 just to
create a little bit of love to our king
maybe ask the bishop what it wants to do
okay
and in the meantime as he's thinking
thank you guys once again
thank you very very much we've got three
thousand plus at this
late hour um watching watching the
speeder and i appreciate everybody's
support
a great deal and it
it's been it's been awesome it's been a
great stream and we'll be finishing up
very soon
but let's try to finish this game off in
style thank you
dayton pergai for the prime okay so
bishop drops back to d2 on its own
volition
and uh it it should not take you guys
long to see that it x-rays the queen
uh there might not be any specific
threat that
that results from this x-ray but i don't
want to play with fire
uh i certainly don't want to play with
fire i want to move this queen away
where do we move this queen away we have
several good squares but since we
already put a rook on c8
we know that the c file is is a nice
uh a nice let's just say hilton
marry it in in suites for the queen and
the rook uh
in in the night or if this is very
common you put the queen on c7 and the
rook on c8
right the queen and the rook staying
staying in a nice little holiday nc file
and uh you might look at this and say
well what does this do exactly why are
we
doubling in the seafarer we're not
attacking the knight like what are you
doing
the night is not hanging the pawn is
perfectly capable of defending this
night well
again this is where the concept of
pressure comes in and pressure is a very
misunderstood
concept by a lot of people pressure
refers to a
sort of a less uh concrete and more
abstract state of the position where
a particular piece let's say cannot move
because if it moves then uh pieces fall
behind it so the knight for example is
under pressure right knight cannot move
because the c2 pawn would have fallen
that's why white plays rook a to c1
uh he's trying to perhaps free up the
knight on on c3 although the knight has
nowhere to go
um yeah there's many good moves here we
can play bishop c4 and trade the bishops
but um again there's no particular need
to do that let's actually play
typical night or moves there is one more
typical night or
move that we have not yet played it is
also a move on the queen side i
mentioned this move
we can expand and create a stronghold
not d5 d5 would blend to the pawn but
the move b5 yeah
b5 expanding on the queen side creating
a sort of i would say almost an outpost
on c4
where we can actually bring the knight
to c4 if we wanted to or the bishop or
even the queen
and also do not forget the queen now has
access to the b7 square
from where it could pressure the e4 pawn
so we have probably
10 possible ways of playing this
position they're all good
so don't think that your proposed line
is necessarily bad because i'm choosing
this i'm just trying to play more night
or flight style
yes if you get them if you have amazon
prime you can subscribe to one channel
per month for free
i'm always honored when you choose my
channel but
zero obligation okay
um we might play for d5 sarah no we
absolutely might thank you andrew
andrew's friend jonathan with the prime
no
actually we will play for a d5 so and
pal ctv thanks for the prime
sorry to pressure you guys okay
no sarab you're absolutely right the
ultimate goal here is to play d5
that's exactly what we're doing and in
order to prepare d5
in the best possible way what kinds of
moves might you guys propose the first
is knight b6 to prepare
d5 yeah uh but but the problem with the
move knight b6
is uh but but be careful right he's
played the move b3 guys
so that knight on b6 is not going to
have prospects
in terms of coming to c4 it's only going
to be preparing d5 let's do something a
little bit more flexible thank you axina
and snapweave both subbing let's do
something a little bit more flexible i
like the move queen b7
this is more flexible because yes it
prepares d5 but it also is a standalone
good move it just pressures the e4 pawn
and we're actually threatening to play
knight c5 here we're actually
threatening to play knight c5 here so
this concept of flexibility i've talked
about many times
you have a particular idea choose the
most flexible way of executing it
which means choose the move that even if
your idea were to fail
even if the roof were to come off and
you were to realize that your plan
is crap the move that you played to
prepare that plan
is in and of itself a healthy move
that's not always going to be possible
but when possible you want to try to do
that
thank you aksinha for two months and
snapweave both
more subs we love subs
thank you thank you okay
and let's see 4 000 viewers jesus louise
geez louise i was planning to end that
one okay so this is okay i'm trekkie
monster and waynok priming
both so what should we do should we go
for d5
or is there a better move
yeah we are endowed with tremendous
opportunities here let's go knight c5
one
two three
i'm just being a jerk okay knight takes
c4 and we win the pawn
and now we can go d5 in the best
possible version
okay so what should we take on e4 with
and both pieces are fine but what do you
guys think
yeah so um i'm always torn on how to
present
whether or not you should trade when
you're up material but the way i'll put
it is this way if you can trade
without any concessions and you are up a
piece
by all so let's trade the queens because
that simplifies our task
why does this force a trade because he
cannot move the queen away he would drop
his bishop
so he has to trade in one where the
other also knight takes d4 as you guys
are pointing out
just a tiny bit uncomfortable the fact
that the knight will be pinned
the queen is undefended white has no way
to exploit that
because you can play d5 on the next move
and support the knight and and
cut out the pin but nonetheless queen
takes e4
is is great we didn't even need to play
d5 we just win the pawn
okay so he chest ninja does opt to give
up the bishop
but now he's two pieces down i think
he's he wants this but this is going to
be very easily dealt with by our
army of pieces we're actually
potentially going to win a third piece
and he resigns good game chess ninja
that was very nice
uh of course you know knight a5
was was the blunder and and you played
well in in the first part of the opening
but after this it was very very hard
really to do anything
significant nonetheless thanks for
continuing to play thanks for being
resilient
um and uh we have a lot of things
nonetheless to discuss think of the w
with the prime
so the night of right now bishop e2
is once again known as a relatively
quiet move uh anatoly karpov
gary kasparov's arch nemesis one of the
strongest positional players in history
was a champion of the bishop e2 move uh
because it's kind of the right balance
of tactics and positional chess
it's still night or so it's still
tactical but it's more positional than
like bishop e3 or bishop g5 thank you
lawrence
selafonte with the prime let me show you
guys one of my most painful experiences
with the movie six and through the lens
of this game through the through the
prism of this tragedy
that i suffered in the 2006
pan-american championships in ecuador
against
jorge quarry who now is a grandmaster
from peru he's rated over 26.50
but back then we were both uh
bright-eyed and bushy-tailed
2000s i will show you guys why
i personally never you know i never
vibed to this move
let me just find this game
and i like showing my games you know
from from the old days just to give you
guys a little bit of a personal touch
you know what
makes me think of openings the way that
i do what were the formative experiences
in
in my chess in my early chess career
okay pan american championships
ecuador i got third place in that
tournament but this was
i had two losses out of nine games both
were in the night offshore
again one against ray robson won against
jorge cory the game against jorge was
significantly more and anonymous with a
five dollar donation thank you for the
instructional videos you are very
welcome my friend thank you so much for
the five dollar
boo nation you can see
that i played the chevening again and
uh a lot of people look at this and say
well wait a second
this is the same as going e5
but we aren't weakening the d5 square so
what the heck is the drawback of this
move well there's a couple of drawbacks
and the first of them is that you
obstruct the bishop so you basically
limit the development of the bishop the
bishop kind of has to be in keto itself
at some point
or you have to find some sort of
alternate arrangement on d7 that's a
whole problem
uh and the second part problem is that
the pawn on e6 as you guys will see is
actually a target and it's a target
due to the very very typical plan of
white eventually going up f4 f5
draft 95 thank you for the three months
the third problem
and this is what corey emphasizes in the
game
is that black is very very cramped and
because black is cramped
it's going to be very hard uh to defend
against certain types of king side
attacks when you go e5 you make it
literally harder for white
to bring about any kind of attack watch
how this game proceeds i seem to do
everything normally that's why
this game basically ended my shivan game
career because i just made normal
development moves okay castle
knight c6 okay he goes out for queen c7
normal okay rookie a bishop f8 that's a
typical defensive idea
now i played rogue b8 to prepare b5
you know i seem to be playing normal
sitalian moves knight a5 to get to c4
here i went g6 to try to blunt the queen
and now look at what he does he goes e5
this move would not have been possible
if black spawn was on e5
and in this position corey plays an
absolutely sick
move this is actually correct this is a
sexy move and it wins the game
on the frickin spot it comes absolutely
a bolt from the blue i thought i was
fine here
and this is a bolt from the blue a super
instructive move
because it turns out that all of black's
pieces are sort of cramped on the bottom
rows
the king is incredibly weak which means
that white can actually just slam a
knight
onto d5 very good sam or uh baslon b
aslan one thank you for the prime sorry
thank you for the tier one
and the game is over he takes d5 bishop
takes d5
and look at the pressure the black is
exerting on the f7 pawn
the problem is that if black takes on e5
with the knight then to add insult to
injury rook takes f7 as possible the
knight cannot take
because if queen takes c7 winning the
queen black has to give up a queen and
he's still gonna get checkmated so
this is just horrible and i played
rookie five bishop f7
now knight e6 again exploiting the
undefended queen thank you another sub
fatal left thanks for the prime
queen queen c6 he plays rook takes the i
mean this is just nasty stuff
now the rook loses its support i play
brook takes e6
and he just starts taking everything
queen e5 track intermediate move
queen takes b8 bishop f7 wins another
piece
and now wins another piece and i resign
so he literally demolished me
and i was a dirty little bastard i mean
bishop b5 at the end by the way
hoping for rook takes c5 queen f1
checkmate but
a guy of jorge cory's caliber nope queen
takes the five checks simple
uh liquidation takes takes takes takes
and he's up a rock
so that was an absolutely brutal game i
lost a couple more like these two
so i was like all right no more no more
chemin again
in the shivan and again the reason that
i struggled in it is not because it's
bad
the chevening again even to this day is
considered to be fine
although e5 is definitely the favorite
move among
among strong grandmasters at this point
but gary kasparov lady6
it's what i would define as a come to
papa system
there are certain systems within
openings that i would define as come to
papa systems
that's systems where you basically you
know you adopt the
the karate kid stands and you're like
just come to papa
these are like the bumper cars right you
just put these out here e6 and d6
come to papa go f5 go e5 i don't want
him to come to papa i want to be the one
coming to papa
okay so that's personally why i don't
like e6 to me
it's too provocative i don't like
playing in
uh this provocative of a style and i
prefer to
uh have a little bit more more space
than myself thank you all perico2 for
the for the prime so does that make
sense
that's partially why uh that's basically
why i i don't like the chevening again
and this game
influenced me and i played the final
schmann again in my life in in 2006 ever
since then i've played e5 with
uh with a good amount of success
um yeah and this is also kind of the
reason that a lot of people don't like
the french you get similar types of
positions
all right so
e5 knight b3 bishop bishop e7
castles castles queen d3 bishop e6 now
queen d3
is a legitimate move but the best way to
follow up with the move queen d3
the point of this move the point of this
move is to
over protect the e4 pawn and
over protection essentially means that
you are freeing up
a piece that was previously protecting a
pawn now that piece
is free to move about the cabin the
captain has turned off the seatbelt sign
the captain has turned off the seat belt
sign for the c3 knight it no longer
is charged with defending the e41 which
means that it could go to d5
now obviously putting a knight on d5
here is
does not come with quite the same effect
as putting the knight on d5 when black
cannot take it
here black can take on d5 and you get a
very interesting structure where white
starts attacking on the queen side
black starts attacking on the king side
and you get this kind of very combative
play on either side of the board i don't
want to delve into this too deeply you
just get an interesting position
queen d3 is one of many possible lines
in this position
okay but bishop g5 is fine of course
knight a5
i get why you play this move it is a
typical move in these positions
sadly it just doesn't uh pass muster
here of course because of the queen
thank you
page aix for the prime
and i think that um maybe rook rook
sorry not rook c1 but maybe rook d1 or
maybe something
peaceful like h3 should have been
preferred although black already has a
very comfortable game after b5
maybe you could also play a4 that's
another very typical night or move for
white
to prevent b5 okay i actually like a4 i
think that would have been white's best
move
and the game continues uh blackberry's
rook c8
you know and and and you go back and
forth so this is this is just a position
uh
okay one moment
yeah so does that make sense right uh a4
is what i would prefer now here
everything else is very simple queen c7
we play the flexible move we get the
knight to e4
and uh and we we take the second piece
and we win the game
so after knight takes a5 uh after queen
takes a5 there was nothing really
interesting that happened
um but yeah i mean
what i would recommend for you ninja if
you want to keep playing this line there
is a move here where you play f4
oh wow look at that synchronization
kishan 2 asking the same question just
as i mentioned that this was possible
that was pretty cool
um yeah so f4 is possible in this
position
but it doesn't quite come with the same
effect
as f4 when the pawn is on e6
and here you can actually take on f4
bishop takes f4
and you get a very very typical
structure
where it may appear that the pawn on d6
now is very weak
but the pawn on d6 just like we've heard
the expression bad bishops defend good
pawns
well bad pawns defend good squares
and the pawn on d6 uh is a supporting
pawn
for a piece that could appear on what
square and we can get that piece there
right now
i can even show you you know i i've done
this many times before
so here's here's a very simple example
from from one of my games
uh warm milking thank you for the prime
so what square am i talking about first
of all
what square am i talking about first of
all
so this pawn yeah e5 and we can get the
knight there by playing knight c6 95 and
that knight on e5
is solid as a rock now have i done
something like this before in one of my
games absolutely this idea of
taking on f4 and then putting a knight
on e5 is about as old
as the hills i mean it literally is one
of the main
one of the formative one of the main
night of ideas in this variation
so here for example in just one moment
you guys will see me applying this id in
one of
my old games
all right
so here we see
one of my old games from 2008 you guys
can see bishop b2e5 at this point i had
already transitioned
you get a4 in this position which is
also a variation we go knight bd7 roxy
hear me here is me playing the typical
moves ipd7 roxy and f4
and you guys will never guess what i did
in this position
you guys will never get what guess what
two moves i played in this position
as old as the lens
it's almost as if we just talked about
how to respond to f4 in the night or
yeah knight takes e4 nah girl he takes
f4
95 beautiful getting the knight onto
this very beautiful square
and he did take the knight but now
essentially
as a result of him taking the knight
this bishop on e7 which lay dormant
now gets a very juicy square on b4 and
black gets a very nice end game position
which i ultimately
um was able to convert into a win so
uh so so so that actually is one of the
key ideas
to know for black if you play in the
night or is to take on f4 and put a
knight on
on e5 that's uh very traditional very
classical
and uh now there's nothing wrong with
that it's just old school
idea okay uh that was a little overview
of the bishop e2 night or there's
so much more to talk about bishop e2 is
a vast line
i'm pretty sure there have been books
written about bishop e2 alone
and there is a you know
there is a ton of sub variations that
each feature their own
uh their own signature thank you jay
daradanos and i actually played one of
the nicest games i've ever played in the
bishop 2 line with black against
alexander shabolov
uh when i was rated about 2350 i beat
shabulov on the black side of
of this line with black having played e5
and um you know once i switched from the
chevening again
it was like i was blind but but but now
i see so
yeah i i played a super nice game
against tribal and that really inspired
me to keep playing the night or
um okay puffy rad thank you for the two
one
man these subs are just flying in and
that's exactly what i like to see
puffy rat says hey daniel i've been
really enjoying your speed on content
you've definitely been opening my eyes
with your clear explanatory style
thank you so much well thank you that is
a very sweet message 7676 as we creep up
once again on 8 000 subs that is just
ridiculous guys
i am just beyond spoiled
i can show you the game against shabala
if people are interested in the game or
i can maybe play one last speed on game
what do people think do you want to see
the game against shabala really quickly
i'm happy to show it uh i don't know i
don't think i've shown it on stream
before
okay you want the speedrun game all
right
speedrun it is let's play who shall we
play
there's selenator who's selenator
it's all good that's why i'm doing it
who is selenator can you announce
yourself
i'll play a a900 maybe
well i'll show charlie the vienna gambit
so you guys will just have to wait until
our next lesson
one moment please well we've got over
four thousand viewers that's crazy
um the vinnie cat 20 thank you for the
tier one
so selenator going once you have to
announce yourself in the chat if you
guys challenge me and i'm about to
accept
i will ask you to announce yourself in
the chat just to make sure
that you can participate in the
post-game analysis
so selenator hi let's go
10-minute gaming insalinator no we have
to coordinate but sometime next week
okay so here what should we play guys
let's play e5
which is something that that selenator
and
selena okay so selenade i think she's
uh probably more familiar with e5 so
let's play something that our opponent
is likely familiar with
um bishop c4 is the italian now um
i have told you guys before that between
the two main moves in this position
there's knight f6
and there is bishop c5 which of the
moves
is safer which of the moves is safer
not better safer bishop c5 because it
doesn't allow the fried lever again the
fried lever is fine for black but you
have to know a lot of theory here
the c3 line is uh is is quite a bit
easier to learn and there's less theory
so knight f6 now
white has d4 or d3 both moves are
two main lines of the italian d3 is the
fashionable line and
we get the main line of the italian this
is all the rage at the high level today
so
okay black's moves are absolutely not
surprising okay we we have to castle
and at some point we play a6 to create a
little
hole a little envelope for the bishop on
a7 we can do that in virtually any order
we can also play h6 uh but bishop g5 is
actually not scary so let's castle and i
will show you guys if selena plays
bishop g5
then we will see why bishop g5 is
actually not scary so
so castles by by by white now uh yeah
let's play h6 to stop bishop g5
uh it certainly is not going to hurt
and then we're gonna play d6 and we're
gonna open up this bishop and try to get
it to g4 if possible
so far we're just developing our pieces
uh literally nothing to write home about
at all
so let's see what cylinator comes up
with here
h3 okay so now we go d6
and uh we get a typical symmetrical
italian position which
it may look boring it's not as boring as
it seems and the selena bliss d4 which
is a sensible move claiming the center
okay
now the key question i look at this
position you have to ask yourselves do
we want to take on d4
uh or not or do we drop our bishop back
to b6
yeah so we certainly um we certainly
don't want to take on d4 why would we
give away
not only all of the center but also let
this knight develop to c3 so
do not you know just take a pawn just
because you can bishop b6 is
much much better and that's the reason
we we played these two moves so that the
e5 pawn would be safely defended now d5
by selena so
she closes down the center and it is
clear that we have to move the night
where do we move
it we need to move the night uh
with already with foreign knowledge of
where that night is going to end up
okay and uh those of you who have played
this
should kind of know that 97 is the
typical retreat square because this
knight from e7
and white has the equivalent idea on the
other side of the board
sorry on the you know reflected side of
the board this knight is going to come
to g6
and the reason that the knight is very
good on g6 is not only because it
it it you know buttresses the king's
position but it can also go to f4 and f4
as you guys know
is a very strong defensive outpost but
knight a3 by selena so
not paying attention to what the threat
is i feel like she didn't ask
what the threat was and it was better to
develop the knight to d2 now we can
actually just take the pawn on e4 that
is a juicy juicy central pawn
and white's position already starts to
crumble so knight takes e4 quite simple
and we are now up upon
and knight e3 uh should not be sneezed
that knight a3 is actually
a typical move in these types of
positions
because sometimes the knight comes to c4
but not oh and now we have a five-head
move
who can spot the tactic who can
swap the tactic bishop on b6 is pinning
the pawn on f2 which means that the
phone cannot move and because white has
played h3
the square on g3 is undefended which
means we can put the knight on g3
and we can fork the rook and the queen i
don't know where that sound came from
knight g3 forks the work on the queen so
the moment that h3 is played literally
you need to make a mental marker okay
the g3 square is now weak
tons and tons and tons of games have
been won
on various tactics related to this
square
particularly in this opening like
literally that is how pervasive this is
and obviously you have the reflected
square on on g6 and and and yeah and so
later collapses here we just with the
queen
um i the bishop e3 makes sense i mean
you intercept the pin but
but sadly the queen is now hanging the
game is over
yeah the game is over here king h2 i
mean bishop takes c2 would have at least
been
uh the lesser evil now our knight can
actually evacuate on what square
and i mentioned the square before
where can this night go
yeah i'm not sure what what people are
doing yeah knight f4 is right
and this pawn on e5 supports tonight
okay oh good
perfect and we are up a queen
isn't that more defense for not moving
the h7 pawn in front of the castle king
well it's more defense for doing it in a
very discriminate in a very uh selective
fashion
uh but but stopping bishop g5 or bishop
g4 is often more important than
weakening the square
like weakening the square is a negative
externality but it's something you just
have to uh
you just have to deal with and solve
when the time comes
all right so g3 we we take the plan
there's many ways to win a position like
this
um in particular we just need to kind of
unfurl
our pieces uh and in order to unfurl our
pieces this knight on e7 where can it go
it's 994 working to go
yeah knight f5 and i'll show you guys by
the way a very very classic russian game
where um this this concept of the weak
g3 square
was exploited in a very beautiful
fashion this game that
i will show you guys after we finished
this game
it made a big impression on me when my
coach showed it to me many many years
ago
and now you will have a chance to go
through if i can find it
now you'll have a chance to go through
the same process
okay 93. and then the queen can come out
to f6
and uh we are attacking the rook on and
yeah queen can come out to f6 attacking
the knight
simply bringing all the pieces into the
game and delivering checkmate quickly
and i take c3 well knight takes g3 just
king takes right that would blunder the
knight
yeah okay
all right
okay bishop before that's a good move
this bishop on e4 can we attack it
while bringing another piece into the
game
probably not guys i'll go to sleep
rookie yeah
uh well quartz schneider definitely had
i think a
win in that maybe that when i'm thinking
about is a quarter game although i'm not
sure
but yeah we'll see
now if the knight moves from f3 then of
course queen f2 check will come yeah
when f2 check will come
and now a simple train of logic
queen g2 would be checkmate if it
weren't for the bit okay bishop g2 just
gonna take g2 if king moves to h1 we can
take that bishop
all right good game selena uh let's take
a quick look
so we had an italian and once again
no it's all good it's all good i
appreciate you putting yourself out
there
uh that was instructive couple of really
cool things that we can take away from
this game
um don't worry about it yeah one of many
one of many
so bishop c4 um knight f6 allows the
fried liver with knight g5 you you
probably play that
selena knight g5 this is the fried liver
and black has to know exactly how to
respond to the pride lever which is d5
ed
and now as i've explained many times
taking on d5 is a very famous mistake
very famous mistake because of knight
takes f set so you have to play the move
knight to a5
this actually sacrifices a pawn so you
have to be able to play this like semi
gambit line
and uh i don't recommend that to to my
students or to beginners i think bishop
c5 is
is just easier to learn so c3 and d3
castles castles this is mainline
h6 h3 is great so you're actually
playing great
and and here i think the problem started
so i just think the move d4
it's tempting but i don't think you're
ready for it because you're not
developed
on the queen side right you can see that
you're particularly your bishop and your
knight are not developed yet
so by playing d4 you are biting more
you are biting off more than you can
chew if that makes sense yeah for two
months that's crazy
so you're following the right principle
but you're slightly biting off more than
you can chew
your prawns just become a little bit too
weak and
you could see that ultimately that's
what what killed you in the end
um so why was bishop g5 not scary
pre-castle so bishop g5
black can simply play bishop back to e7
and the bishops are now at the standoff
which
where they basically nullify each other
castles d6
and you might argue well hasn't black
lost the tempo yes but now the bishop on
g5 is like
super awkward and black can actually
sidestep the entire operation with
knight h5 knight f4 so this is actually
the theory
and and this is fine for black so
castle's uh
h6 and the main move selena is well
white has several moves you can play
bishop out to e3
sorry in this position you can play
bishop out to e3
uh but the the sort of purest way of
playing is to go knight b to d2
then rookie one and selena i want you to
tell me if you are familiar
with this maneuver where can this knight
go
where can this night why why do we play
rookie one because it looks kind of
stupid why are we putting the rook on a
closed file
well we're doing that to vacate a
particular pathway for the knight
and if you play the italian you have to
be aware of of this maneuver
yes knight f1 is correct so bishop a7
knight f1
black can do the same thing and then you
get the knight g3 with the ultimate aim
of getting it perhaps to f5 at some
point
you don't want to do that immediately
because bishop takes f5 but you want to
kind of hover over that
square and now you get a very
complicated position i don't want to
delve too deeply into it
but this is ultimately like the uh
the theory here okay so d6 d4 bishop b6
d5
97 and hear the decisive mistake already
uh because after you lose the pawn it's
just incredibly hard to play this
position now how should you have
defended the spawn
well i think knight bd2 was possible
developing the knight and defending the
pawn
i would have gotten knight g6 knight f4
here and
and i like black's position but you can
definitely play you can still go rookie
one knight f1 knight g3 and white is
still fine but after knight a 394
perhaps here bishop e3 was one way to
keep
the game going uh because this pin is
is really really devastating and once
you play h3 you have to pay attention to
the g3 square
now um and after queen e2 knight g3
unfortunately
uh you know you you should have moved
the queen but the reality is once i win
the exchange it's it's very very hard to
defend
you fought valiantly but you know once i
win the queen it's just
too many pieces and too many attackers
nonetheless that was a great game
really appreciate it and um you know it
gives us a chance to talk
quite a bit about an opening that a lot
of people play so that's just awesome
now let me look up there is a game that
i
referenced there was a game that i
referenced where
black basically exploited
that weakness of the g3 square in
another opening
but he did so to great effect and
there's actually many games that feature
a similar concept
let me see it is black to play
in this position and this is a game
not of the person i i thought of but of
uh
francisco vale vallejo ponz
who is a very very strong grandmaster
from spain
and he will demonstrate for us the
application of this concept so we we see
here
a couple of similarities this came from
a french
but we can see here uh the fact that the
g3 square is very weak
and we see the same the exact same pin
that the bishop is exerting but
if we play queen g3 immediately
that move does not actually come with as
great effect as it may seem
because uh white can simply intercept
the bishop white can intercept the
bishop and you can do so with bishop e3
right the problem is you are already
threatening to capture the queen if
bishop takes c3 then rook takes e3
and i mean you cannot play bishop takes
h3 anymore because of f takes g3 but
what can you do what can you do and this
is something you must check for
in any situation where you have two
moves you want to play
what happens if i switch the move order
thank you running cat dog indeed
everybody's gotta watch that still you
take on hp first
the point is if g takes h3 now this move
comes with check
not only does it come with check if you
go king f1 then you get checkmated
and if you go king h1 well um i'm not
exactly sure
what black's best option is probably
bishop takes f2
and and then queen takes oh yeah no then
you take the knight and queen takes h3
and
black basically just gets a devastating
attack so uh valyejo's opponent did not
take on hp but who won queen g3 anyway
and uh he used that g3 square as a
springboard
and uh now his pieces combined to
pressure the pawn and he ultimately won
a very nice game
so not an ideal illustration but you can
see that in many different openings in
many different positions
this particular square on g3 is very
important or correspondingly the square
on g6
is very important when there is a pin
going on
along these corresponding diagonals but
also move
uh switch or switch around the move
order you have to check for that that's
very very important
okay um
so any questions about this game and
selena you know don't be
don't be shy i mean really anything you
want to know
uh it's uh you know the italian is a
very hard opening to master particularly
if you just started
you're gonna make these mistakes for a
while i mean charlie has been making
these mistakes for like a year
and now we can see that he's uh
things are starting to come together for
him in certain types of positions
was d5 a mistake blocking the bishop
yeah d5 was inaccurate
uh but i understand why why selena
played this i mean at this point
uh white has to be very careful to keep
his center to keep her center protected
um maybe d takes e5 is is a bit of a
bailout move but
maybe something like this just like
keeping the pawn protected
uh probably would be would be a
reasonable course of
action although black of course has
solved all of his opening problems